[Music]
23 years for 23 years you've been a
Marine that's right 3 years of marine
this guy you probably you probably know
how to kill Andy and I very quickly and
I don't talk to many celebrities who
would know how to do that but you you
really do know how to kill us yeah yeah
yeah I think that you sit with a big
smile to do well I just I didn't want to
stress how much I actually think about
it but yeah I think about it a lot guys
yeah yeah you have I haven't even
started begging you yeah no I know it's
it's the weirdest thing though when
you're in the military and you've
deployed or wherever you think you start
to get a tactical mind you just think
tactically so even though you're retired
now from the military technically you
still think tactically when you're in
every just in everyday life I'm not
kidding now if I go into a restaurant if
I go into a room I know all my egress
points I know what I'm gonna do if
there's trouble it's just like if I'm
dried I was out on the golf course today
and I was like this is a great place for
an ambush right here if I was setting
this up look at that saddle right there
there's a Ridgeline hole this is
dynamite crossfire I would not want to
be here honestly as I really relaxing to
golf with you oh yeah I did blow your
head off like a melon right I mean
honestly right now I'm looking around
this room and if if the trouble went
down I would go for the curtain because
that's got good concealment and I hate
to tell you this but I would use you as
a human shield problem no one would
blame you I mean just me as a big floppy
human shield ugly
you